dozens of disaster declarations and
states of emergency are in effect across
New York New Jersey and Pennsylvania
after heavy rain and historic flooding
Russian water destroyed hundreds of
homes this morning the flood waters are
starting to recede as the cleanup begins
Tony - copal is in Hector New York with
the latest on this story waterlogged
residents in upstate New York were hit
with another round of storms for the
third day in a row
rescue crews spent the day looking for
people trapped by rising waters in
Seneca County just to the south and
Montour Falls floodwaters turned a
normally serene view into a violent
deluge of rushing water in the town of
Lodi a sinkhole opened on a roadway
while dozens of people were trapped by
floodwaters and debris New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo toured Lodi and other hard
hit areas Tuesday he declared a state of
emergency in more than a dozen counties
this is a different pitch from Mother
Nature and it causes problems and areas
that haven't seen it before just south
of the New York border in Franklin forks
Pennsylvania emergency crews were busy
rescuing people trapped in their homes
unable to get out in time because the
floodwaters rose so quickly almost got
swept away a couple of times by the
water so kind of see your life flash
before your eyes it's pretty terrifying
in New Jersey people in the hard-hit
town of brick started the long process
of cleaning up and rebuilding
officials say 85 homes here were flooded
I don't know what we're gonna do I don't
have to find a new place to live I don't
that's really carefully there are scenes
like this all over the region and
Corning New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
is saying about a hundred and thirty
additional National Guard troops and
some 30 vehicles will be available
hardest hit areas